[Music]
hey you guys here we are tom's got his
black sexual tyrannosaur hat on today
yeah it's maximizing my [ __ ] toxic
masculinity
so um
we saw i am legend
and uh
i totally misre misremembered this movie
from a long time you're a thing of the
whole [ __ ] different movie well maybe
i think i saw i think i saw part of it
but i had a lot wrong but but you know i
think i confused parts of it with
another movie with it a long time ago it
was a lot better than i remembered
um
i still like a mega man better we're
going to get into it
but it was a lot better than i
remembered
it was a bit better than i remembered i
mean i probably hadn't seen it since
2008
2009 i didn't see it in the theater but
like somebody loaned it to me like when
it came out um you know i used to work
with a guy who loaned me movies all the
time yeah and i think i probably saw it
then so i saw it a couple years after it
came out and i remember it being like i
was like ah that's pretty good i was
like i don't like the ending though
because it wasn't really like the book
but
i kind of remembered it was okay but it
was actually like better than i
remembered you for some reason i thought
that only new york was affected and that
they sent him in there to go stop the
um
the outbreak yeah see that sounds like a
different movie yeah um no he was he it
was the same premise he was kind of like
the last man on earth he finds some
other people but
um it was it was worldwide the pandemic
he was on his own in there so that
particular element of the story was was
left intact
the only thing i didn't like about the
movie is that the mutants didn't talk so
that that really dumbed the story down a
lot
you know a lot of the [ __ ] nuances
that were in omega man or uh even
uh last man on earth
kind of vanished when
the mutants don't have a culture or a
language so there's no relationship you
know there's no characters there
although they did do some stuff they
were interacting with him you know like
mimicking his traps and [ __ ]
so evidently they did
understand him to a certain extent but
they were just kind of animalistic kind
of like rage zombies did a lot of
screaming um
they're cgi and they
it doesn't hold up they look terrible
yeah the cgi is really balls in this
it's yeah good and there was absolutely
no need for cgi they could have been
with the characters the design that they
were doing with the with the zombies
they could have just been people
well see i think they did i mean at
least from what i read on wikipedia i
think they did do it with actors first
with makeup and stuff and they didn't
like the way it looked so then they
figured out well we'll just use the
actors and then we'll do motion capture
and then we'll do it all in cgi but the
i'm sure that yeah i'm sure like i mean
the cgi people still talk about how [ __ ]
it is yeah um
and if it had been people i think it at
least would have i mean because
it's not like these things had to be
monsters they were just
mutated people yeah i mean pulled that
[ __ ] off in the mega man great just with
a pair of [ __ ] contact lenses and
some it's a white [ __ ] yeah they
didn't have to look like they don't have
to look that different they didn't yeah
they didn't have to look like exotic
creatures or anything well look at what
the walking dead was doing with [ __ ]
real life that's what i'm saying come on
yeah come on well we've always said this
i mean practical effects are always
gonna if they're done well they're all
they're never going to age they're going
to date yeah so it's always better to
use that cgi is always going to like be
dated i think
had it been actual actors doing the
[ __ ]
mutants
this movie could have stood with the
other two and aged
well right along with them you know what
i mean and been more more of a cult
classic
but this one i think is just going to be
kind of forgotten just because it aged
out so quickly with those effects
just it's sad because second will smith
does a good job in it he's great in this
i had forgotten like what a good actor
because you have to think for about
two-thirds of this movie
he there's no other people for him to
act against yeah it's just basically him
and the dog yeah you know what i mean
and he does a fantastic job yeah i mean
he's really really good in this i think
this is like easily one of his best
roles i'd have paid to see him slap
chris tucker though
yeah yeah yeah
[Laughter]
yeah but um yeah so well did you watch
the alternate ending
i don't know what ending we saw
we saw the theatrical ending okay
because we watched it on amazon prime so
i didn't see the i didn't see the yellow
and i told you i was like well go on
youtube because somebody's posted the
alternate ending and indeed they have
because it's on the thing so the thing
you were saying before about the mutants
not being like characters in this that's
sort of addressed a little bit in the
alternate ending it's not hugely
different but it kind of like changes
the whole tone closer to the book but
still not exactly the same
so obviously in the theatrical ending um
much like i am legend or a a mega man
rather
you know will smith uh sacrifices
himself like he gives his the blood like
the viru the the vaccine or whatever to
the people like the survivors and he's
like get out of here i'm going to like
blow all these monsters up
into his closet yeah even though he
could have fit in there too it's like i
don't know why because i was watching a
video earlier and said why didn't he
just throw the grenade at them and then
all three of them leave
instead of just me and i was like i
didn't yeah i didn't think the final
ending scene was worthy but yeah but the
alternate the alternate ending yeah what
happened was it was kind of the same
thing they're trapped in this glass room
like all the monsters come in there and
one of them like bangs his head against
the glass and it makes a shape like a
butterfly
and then he notices that you remember
the female monster that he was
experimenting on has a butterfly tattoo
on her neck
and he realizes that this is the mate of
that one and it came to rescue her like
[ __ ] you were experimenting on my
girlfriend okay and so he realizes oh my
god like they
are the same as us like they have the
same emotions as us
and you know then he says okay we'll
take her back and he and the the monster
gets like all like emotional about it
like oh my god i got my wife back or
whatever and he realizes holy [ __ ] i've
been killing all of these people
like to experiment on them so just like
in the original book he realizes oh my
god i'm a monster to them because i've
been killing him and experimenting on
him when they have feelings just like we
do um but he does live you know i mean
he doesn't die like he does in the book
yeah that's
so it's closer yeah that's still not a
very good ending no i'm not saying that
i'm just saying that it's better than
the theatrical and right it's better
than the theatrical ending they should
have been talking the whole way that
would have made a lot more sense and
they should have you know they should
have been more like something out of the
omega man and uh and [ __ ] uh
and last man on earth they should have
been basically rational but [ __ ]
crazy you know they get me or no well
how can you be rational crazy you know
what i'm talking about
they were totally rational you couldn't
really reason with them but they were
you know they could speak
they kind of had their own
culture
yeah i mean that's the thing though i
mean
and i think we talked about this
yesterday we were talking about the
omega man it seems like nobody now
interestingly this movie just like every
other feels like a lot of big movies
like this
warner brothers um had done omega man
right because they had the rights to
richard matheson's novel like going back
to 1970.
so it was their idea to do another
update of it
and they started working on it back in
the mid 90s
and one of the earliest iterations like
they were gonna get tom cruise to be in
it like i think mel gibson was gonna be
and arnold schwarzenegger was gonna be
in it at one point but i think ridley
scott was supposed to direct it when
they were doing it i was like 95 97
somewhere around there and ridley scott
was gonna do it
and they had done
from what i haven't read the script that
they did but from what i read of the
idea that they had that ridley scott had
they were gonna do it more like the book
it was gonna be a lot more like downbeat
you know what i mean whereas just like
the book is because the book is kind of
like i don't want to say it's like
nihilistic it's not exactly nihilistic
but
it's they still haven't done as i said
yesterday they still haven't done
they still haven't done a movie
interpretation of it that gets close to
the theme of the book really they always
kind of like go off on their own kind of
tangent this one has a similar it's not
as
it's not as messianic i guess as a mega
man with all the jesusy symbolism this
one has a little bit of that
but not as much but it's still kind of
still like a hero
type journey whereas the whole point of
the book as i've brought up before is
that
the who the person you're thinking is
the hero the whole time is actually kind
of the villain you know what i'm saying
and i i feel like no movie has really
got that and maybe they thought
everyone's would get bummed out about it
but
i don't know i mean this movie it made a
[ __ ] ton of money it made like almost
600 million dollars right so
but the thing about it is that a lot of
people that maybe liked it at the time
a lot of people just kind of like forgot
about her i was like ah that was okay
it's like it's not really remembered all
that much and i think the only reason
people
think about or remember is like oh kind
of we didn't like the ending like other
than the alternate ending yeah
i mean there's but there's good things
about it like i said i had hadn't seen
it for you know a long time like at
least like 15 years or so
and
um will smith is great in it the first
part where he's like on his own that's
fantastic i'm i'm into it
um you know and i liked some of the
changes that they made again like uh
much like omega well omega man it was um
the virus was uh germ warfare right yeah
in this one it was almost kind of like a
cancer
cure that mutated and caused this big
thing so it's almost like we're a victim
of our good intentions type [ __ ] which
that's more in line with like the times
i guess of whatever
um so i kind of liked that i liked the i
liked the interaction with him and the
dog and him having like a relationship
with the dog like in the book it was
just like a random stray that he kind of
kept for a little bit until it died but
i i didn't like that they killed the dog
though like i get what they were going
for like to but come on well the dog
died in the in the uh in the book in the
first movie i know but
you but yeah but you hadn't been with
this dog and the character hadn't been
with the dog because in this version
it's established that he like when he
put his family on the helicopter to get
out of manhattan they handed him the
puppy like here take you know the dog
will take care of your whatever so he's
had this dog for three years and it's
the last thing that connects him to his
dead family
um so it's a lot more like emotion so
like i know why they did it it has like
a much more big bigger emotional impact
but i still get bummed out when they
kill animals in movies you know what i
mean like i said kill all the people you
want leave the puppies and kitties alone
but yeah that was kind of that was kind
of a bummer but i don't know um
i was just like what's his
cast the way the dude had to lose wilson
never yeah
that was wilson basically yeah well yeah
that's the thing that and that was like
his only living companion and that's
kind of what spurred him to be like [ __ ]
it i don't even want to live anymore and
that's what made him go out at night and
start plowing down like uh mutants with
his truck and [ __ ] like one of the
changes that they made he's still like a
colonel
you know i guess he's a
in bio warfare he is he decides to stay
there when he didn't have to because he
thinks he can get the situation under
control that he could stop the outbreak
and and he also wants to cure the
infected
the the the
and but and he's kind of [ __ ]
pathological about it he doesn't want to
leave he can't he's crazy um
because the pandemic's over everybody's
dead
it's just those you know
and uh another change that they made is
uh
he's not as uh he's not as militant
as as as as heston's neville was
like you look at his inside his house it
just looks like a doctor's house
well he's a virologist that's what he's
supposed to be yeah it's not i mean he's
military too but right
it's definitely not like an armed castle
it's because they're not really
attacking him
well now i'm gonna say that that is one
thing that i actually kind of liked
about this change i'm glad you reminded
me of that because prior to like in the
like last man on earth and in omega man
it seemed like the mutants are showing
up like every night yeah like trying to
get into it and you think after three
years they would have been able to like
get in and kill him right i mean it
seems like what the [ __ ] is their
problem now but in this one he the the
mutants don't know where he lives
and so he's pretty much safe he's got
like all the things like over the
windows and [ __ ] like that so just in
case and he's got they show like um
toward the end he actually has like
booby traps like all outside so just in
case he's prepared yeah but they don't
know where he lives until he does that
stunt with the driving around at night
because he gets mad because his dog dies
and then you know he meets uh what's her
face from predators and
it's just not the same character but
what's her face from predators and
the kid yeah and they take him back to
the house and it's at night and so the
mutants follow them and then they
subsequently find out where he lives and
then they bust into the house and they
would have killed them you know what i
mean so i like that better because
you know the other movie versions
you know if you've been in this house
for three years i don't care how good
your defense is big like gangs of people
kind of like try to bust in your house
and kill you they're gonna get in over
three years you know what i'm saying
they're not that stupid well i don't
know
or weak yeah you think they would figure
it out in omega man they were sick first
of all and they were they used to be
civilians most of them
and they were led by a tv reporter
all right
looks like they only had one guy that
really knew what was up and that was
zach
brother zachary
and then because of their religion they
couldn't use any modern weapons so
neville had fortified himself with a
bunch of modern weaponry
so they were mostly just came up and
trolled him remember and they'd burn
this burn the place next to him and
[ __ ] yell yeah i guess they were
mostly just like they were just [ __ ]
with them yeah they were mostly trolling
him
and uh they were scared of him
basically when they came out with the
catapult neville didn't even shoot them
he just shot up the catapult they went
running
running and laughing
and then he was looking for him during
the day he was trying to kill him in
their sleep which they didn't make that
real clear in omega man which that's why
i wanted there was some changes i would
have done i would have showed him that
he was actually looking to just wipe
them out in their sleep but they never
showed him not even once because like i
said that's kind of what he was doing in
the book
and they showed that in last man on
earth yeah like vincent price was going
around staking some of them when they
were just or when they just like woke up
like oh [ __ ]
like yeah
so they needed to have that you know
mega man to to let the audience know
that that's actually what he was doing
and trying to get him while they were
asleep
you know
that's what made him a legendary monster
in their minds yeah because he'd come
when you were at your at your weakest
and
they would go to his house and [ __ ]
troll him and
shoot flaming balls at him
but because of you know that he had
those walls and everything you know big
flood lights that they couldn't get
close to the house you remember yeah
they had the flood lights he had
floodlights kept him out
and because of all that he was kind of
impregnable they were jealous of him you
know him living up there in his honky
paradise you know they were [ __ ]
and then he was a relic of the past so i
i liked it was it's plausible that he
could keep
that many of them out and there really
weren't that many of them
there were maybe you know
i'd say there were only 30 of them
yeah that's true you know i'm just
saying yeah i mean i guess it would
stand to reason in that version that
it's like well they didn't really want
to get it yeah because they could have
they could have if they really wanted to
yeah
and uh
well if they'd use the technology that's
why brother zack says let me go to the
national guard armory i'll get that damn
outlet certainly we'll blow him out of
there with a cannon and like oh no we're
not going to use any of the old ways
they're [ __ ] crazy
you know yeah they were [ __ ] crazy
they could they couldn't he's a user of
the wheel and all that kind of [ __ ]
which i thought that was good because
they had to have a balance it had to be
a way to balance out the numerical
superiority they had over they wouldn't
they refused to use technology
so
yeah but i mean i did kind of like
i did kind of like that change in this
version now i guess that the monsters
were around because there was a scene
near the beginning where he was sleeping
in the bathtub with his dog and he could
kind of hear like far away shrieks and
stuff so i get but i don't think they
knew where he was
but the thing about it was that they
were established as these strong and
kind of wily and intelligent creatures
so had they knew where he lived and they
wanted to kill him obviously they could
have got in and i like that they so they
didn't really he didn't really they
didn't come to the house until they
found out where it was and then the same
night they found out where it was or the
next night or whatever they pretty much
like started tearing and they got in
like right away you know what i mean so
i kind of like that
better i guess
i don't know jenny well it's i mean it
works better with the context of this of
that story like i said we're we're far
removed from the book now so from the
book so you know for him the movie is
called i am legend for this for that to
make sense based on the other three
movies and the other two movies in the
books
the bet the the the [ __ ] vampires or
the the mutants would have to have he
would have to be a legend to them so
they had to at least be able to speak
and to talk about him and they'd he'd at
least be a threat to them
and it was just
the way they didn't know mega man is
right that's the way it should have been
done he was in a damn basically a
fortress that they couldn't get into and
during the day he was going out and
hunting them in their sleep and that
would have scared them and it really
shouldn't and they shouldn't have been
[ __ ] real super physically powerful
like these things these things could
just rub the side of a wall and
bash open [ __ ] bulletproof glass with
their heads and stuff it just didn't
make any sense to me maybe it would make
more sense if they were actually kind of
frail like they were in omega man they
were sick they were dying that made more
sense to me
yeah that's true you know um
and which would made
neville
more of a monster to them that he was
basically physically and technologically
superior to them
that's that the only thing that they had
in their advantage was uh the cover of
darkness and numbers
you know
which i think that works out better
i mean it's not a bad movie the way they
did it here it's just it's it's a
different take on drifted away
a lot
well like i said none of the adaptations
are the same as the book the vincent
price one is the closest that's probably
about 90 95 accurate the ending is a
little bit different but not that much
um the other two like deviate wildly but
the and the thing about it what they did
okay so with the theatrical version of
this movie the 2007 one
they justified the title i am legend by
saying that oh will smith became a
legend because he sacrificed himself to
get the vaccine
to the humans okay so they did justify
it like when some voice over [ __ ] at the
end that the lady from predators said
okay when they got to the encampment
like in vermont where the other humans
were so they flipped it
yeah so they flipped legend too right
i'm saying that [ __ ] i liked it the
net the the the heston way where neville
is monstrous he's a monstrous militant
dude who's [ __ ] going out like an
exterminator [ __ ] exterminating them
[ __ ] and they're they're scared of
him you know he's a legend to them a
monster he's the last of the monsters
yeah well and that was the kind of that
was kind of the point of the book too
that's that's kind of cool he's a legend
in a bad way he was a legend like
vampires were to humans
like a scary monster yeah i would
i wish the will smith movie would have
preserved that line of thinking the
alternate ending is a little bit like
that it's well at least it's more like
that than the theatrical ending is yeah
you know what i mean yeah at least the
alternate ending has him realizing oh
[ __ ] i'm the monster because i've been
killing all of these
people all of the all of the mutated
people and like experimenting on them
but he still gets to live like i i think
like the there's a point where the
mutant like the alpha male is what they
call them like uh on the
if you read a description um he he
thinks about killing him for
experimenting on his wife or whatever
but then he's like no he lets him go but
will smith like then goes on to like
live with the guilt that he actually
killed all of these people that were
intelligent and had the same like
feelings as him and [ __ ] like that so he
felt really bad about it so they did
kind of like go in that direction but he
doesn't get killed like i said in the
book
well he doesn't exactly die in the book
they just leave it a little bit open
like but he's going to die you know what
i mean and then in the vincent price
version he does die
um and then oh mega man he dies too but
he dies like the jesusy like he's like
self-sacrifice so that so that's not for
the not for the mutants he does it for
the for for for lisa and the kids
and dutch
well that's what he that's what he does
in the theatrical
ending of this one too okay
but yeah he gives it to the people and
it says hey take this to
the the thing because in the book
um there really aren't any people left
so there's no point to doing that it
could have been there's no vaccine or
nothing there's also there's also some
religious messaging in here too yeah i
don't you know um i thought will smith
was a scientologist and scientologists
don't actually accelerate christianity
that well they claim to but they don't
um
so i don't know who put the messaging in
there might have been scientology i
don't know if they had anything to do
with this movie
um and it it because of that in there
there's a chance that will smith
stipulated that he did not want to be
any kind of feeling in the movie so
maybe they changed some stuff like that
maybe he would have thought that
the charlton heston angle and the
[ __ ] vincent priced angle where a
little too much toxic masculinity or
something i don't know
yeah i mean well that's the thing but
like i said the whole point of the story
and it's most clear in the vincent price
version is that you're supposed to
relate to this character like oh my god
it's like the world is overrun with
monsters and he's going around like
destroying them like in self-defense but
then you find out at the end no these
aren't monsters they're just like the
next stage of evolution or whatever and
this is the last human left and he's
going around wiping him out and they're
all [ __ ] terrified of him and that
was kind of like the whole point of the
book and i don't really feel like the
there hasn't been a movie that's gotten
that exactly right right
i do kind of feel like i don't know if
this is true or not but when they were
first working on making this movie like
back in the 90s and i heard that ridley
scott when he was going to direct it
like he was going to make it at least
look more like the book or more like
bleak or more more of a downer which
because the book is kind of a downer
like i said there's no no there's no
cure in the book because there's no
people left yeah you know what i mean um
there's no people left that aren't
infected and the ones that are infected
that's just well that's just how people
are now you know what i mean so this guy
is like the last one he's like the old
guard and he's you know he's gone in the
heston version of it
there's uh
heston shows no mercy to the to the uh
to the mutants and the mutants don't
really show any mercy to him they're
[ __ ] kind of like eternal enemies
but he does die and he does save the
last of the unaffected uh uninfected
kind of humans
so that's that's the difference
yeah
[ __ ] because hester's like now we're
gonna need to wipe them all out or yeah
they're all dead anyway [ __ ] them you
know that kind of [ __ ] he never there
was no remorse per se he hated him said
they were vermin and they hated him
there wasn't any kind of mutual
understanding
yeah that's i kind of like that angle
yeah and i mean like i said i'm not
averse to um you know doing different
takes on the story that's fine it's just
to me it seems like none of the movies
have gotten the book right they they
don't really seem to
they don't seem to understand or don't
seem to want to convey like what the
theme of the book is yeah um i mean like
i said last minute earth is the closest
but
all of them kind of have a little bit
like it but this one it's just
this one seems like a zombie movie um
they kind of like change it up because i
think 28 days later had come out
uh the year before this or the same year
i can't remember it's basically rage
zombies yeah so this was kind of or
actually maybe 28 days later came out a
couple years before this maybe it was
2004. but um but yeah so i kind of feel
like this was you know jumping more off
of that
i kind of like that they moved it to
new york city um they initially did that
well for a while i mean because the book
is la i think and the original movies
are and uh omega man is l.a
but um they were gonna do i think the
ridley scott when they were gonna do it
in houston
but
i like that they did new york city on
this but because they said
and they actually shot a lot of [ __ ] on
location in this which is crazy because
they don't usually do that a lot in new
york because like i said it's really
crowded and what they did was they shot
on location and then they tried to block
off certain streets i'm imagining like
while they were doing it but then they
just went back and like if anybody
walked through the shots or anything
like that they just digitally erased
them
so
i mean they actually shot like the whole
helicopter thing they shot that on the
brooklyn bridge and
all the locations that you see are real
it's just sometimes they had to like
wipe some people out of the background
so it looked like it was empty but they
said that's easier to do you know and
they said it would have more of an
impact because new york city never looks
empty like at any time of the day or
night so new york looking empty would be
like much more impactful
yeah kind of watson said they were using
the wheel on the catapult though yeah
they also used the wheels on the
vehicles that they [ __ ] rolled out
there in front of his jeep
yeah kind of used kind of hard to do
[ __ ] without a wheel yeah i mean
that's why cavemen invented yeah that
was just kind of something matthias
throughout their user of the wheel
sticking of electric oil and electric
circuitry
you're like whatever yeah man
[Laughter]
oh my god so uh 789 tundra said jenny's
the wig master she looks great in every
wig thank you very much this is my i
think this is my favorite one of all the
colors that i have
i like this one on the purple one but
yeah people are saying that they went
with the not the non-talking ones
because like the zombies were in there
that's what i'm saying it was kind of
like
it was kind of like 28 days later right
you know sorta
or like a lot of other that's the thing
i just kind of feel like they were i
don't know if
i don't know if i like the idea of them
necessarily being
i don't think you should do it again
like the omega man where it was just
where they were very like pretty much
just people
um but like with weird ideas same will
smith as a scientologist my
understanding will smith is a
scientologist i didn't think he was i
thought they were trying to get him in
there
but i don't i don't know if he ever
joined i thought i thought his wife jada
was also a scientologist he was doing
stuff for cult of scientology but it's
been years maybe he maybe he walked i
don't know yeah i don't think he ever
like officially joined but i could
totally be wrong about that right i mean
he never comes up on lists of like hey
celebrities that are scientologists like
elizabeth moss and stuff all right um
and uh who's that other [ __ ] that's a
that's a scientologist giovanni robison
i thought he was a scientologist
he did
do some stuff for him and said some [ __ ]
at one time but [ __ ] that was that was
like
2005 i think 2004 around that time that
if i remember correctly
scientology was
would court those people you know well
yeah they wanted anybody that was super
famous and had a lot of money yeah and
it would kind of work out for a while or
it wouldn't work out there was there's
been a lot of them the the
that [ __ ] went in and out of
scientology and nobody knows about it
but they were like only but they were
like in the initial contact
phase and they're like nah i ain't doing
this tammy says will smith is a
christian he's a christian now okay
well i mean i think he has been like i
said i don't think he was ever a
scientologist not that i ever heard of i
mean maybe like i said maybe they were
trying to get him in there and maybe
he's like okay fine i'll show up at one
of your events but i don't really think
that he ever i mean as far as i know i
got to go back and check i never heard i
got to go back and check and i've never
seen him come up on any list i'm not
sure he went up his did his ot levels
already that that's what i'm saying i
don't think but i think he might have
been public scientologist for a while in
other words i think he might have been
buying some scientology courses
i think you know because [ __ ]
tom cruise was involved in that and
[ __ ] know what's his name you know
john travolta was in in that and a bunch
of other ones a couple of other ones in
there oh
[ __ ]
old fat girl what's her name [ __ ]
kirsty allen kirsty alley that was so
funny we had a guest on one time angry
gay pope he's a friend of mine on the
[ __ ] yeah tammy said he was raised
baptist you raised baptist okay
[ __ ] angry gay pope so he's
constantly out there for controlling the
scientologist we did a show on him you
guys you guys can go back i don't
remember what episode it was and he had
him on as a guest
and he used to have a [ __ ] funny ass
channel and he would go to all the
scientology
events
and there's one where christianity's
walking across the street he yells at
her he's on camera he goes kirsty you
pulled that ass in just on yourself
kirsty and you pulled that fat ass in on
yourself because you see scientologists
blame themselves for everything that
they do based on their thoughts
and if you get fat it's because you
thought about it that's it
you thought about it and you weren't
working scientology prophecy and you get
a big fat ass because of that and
[ __ ]
angry gay pope was reminding
christianity that it was her [ __ ] up
scientology that gave her that big old
fat ass well yeah because they say if
you're ksw yeah keeping scientology
working then you won't have to then you
won't then you'll be perfect perfect
meaning you won't need glasses you'll
have super powers yeah you want to have
to you won't [ __ ] ever age you don't
uh you won't die which yeah yeah even
though el ron hubbard died good no he
didn't he just discarded his body
his body he dropped this they said he
dropped he had to go do some important
[ __ ] on
[ __ ] planet he went on to the next to
the next um ot level to go do important
ot work he'll be back later they are
waiting for him they actually said that
to a room of adults like with a straight
face and everybody believed it i was
like man you guys are stupid as [ __ ]
anyway all these houses are ready for
them they they take care of all those
houses and they're ready for him to come
back grown ass adults yep
yeah uh oracle says jenny glad to hear
you enjoyed watching the first food that
built america episode yes we are
enjoying that very much yeah we're
actually ahead of the segment yeah we
watched the second one last night the
second one which is about uh hershey and
mars yeah and all that yeah yeah it's
really really fun yeah well hershey was
like the only nice guy out of all of
them yeah he seemed like the only i mean
unless some bad [ __ ] happens later on he
actually like yeah everyone else is kind
of a dick yeah well
being ruthless was like a it was a
[ __ ] um what do you call it uh that
was like a virtue yeah in the 1800s
being a ruthless businessman they were
[ __ ] bad i mean i guess out of the
kellogg brothers because like dr kellogg
and we did a show about him about this
the sanitarium and all that kind of
stuff like the invention of cornflakes
um
yeah he he was a he was a big [ __ ]
[ __ ] but um his brother [ __ ] yeah
that guy was a big [ __ ] brother's all
right the brother seemed all right i
mean considering like how he got treated
he went over factory towns and you know
kellogg's he wanted to have a good town
out there
or was that hershey
that was hershey's hershey built the
whole time he was the one that was
hershey pennsylvania yeah and he wanted
he wanted a real good town out there
people would be proud to work there that
type of stuff yeah i thought kellogg
said that too
didn't either one he had it torn down no
that was hershey he had some [ __ ] torn
down no no kellogg um they're like will
kellogg after he got rights to the name
the factory burned to the ground and he
had to rebuild it oh that's what you're
thinking about yeah it was hershey the
one
yeah hershey built the whole town like i
said it's still there hershey yeah but
remember he he looked at the blueprints
because this looks cheap
yeah but um yeah so we've kind of
wandered far from yeah we got to talk
about scientology yeah um
so it's it's a decent movie it's it's a
decent movie i still like omega man the
best out of him um
um but and i want to see last man on
earth again but this is this is decent
it's just it's better than i remember
yeah it's a lot better like i remembered
watching it and being like that was all
right but and sucked right um when i
rewatched it i was like well then kind
of stuck suck still but the rest of it's
okay yeah i don't like the cgi
um the rage zombie
yeah i don't love that but there's like
some [ __ ] about it i do like i mean i
think that will smith uh is amazing in
it he's really really good in it um i
like the dog i like the interactions
with him and the dog and i don't know i
i like a couple of the changes that they
made from the book like i said that the
you know mutants didn't know where he
lived until later on in the movie like i
kind of like that kind of stuff so i
liked some of the changes that they made
it's not a great movie
but it's not a bad it's decent it's
watchable um i you know i had a good
time with it so yeah it was a lot better
than i remembered i didn't remember like
i said i don't remember being terrible i
just remember it being like ah that was
all right kind of thing i'm not you know
you guys know i'm not super into like
big
blockbuster type movies generally this
guy the guy that directed this i can't
remember what his name was but um he's
the same guy that did like i think he
did like the hunger games movies and
stuff like that so he's kind of known
for doing sort of like big blockbuster
type movies which like i said i don't
usually like those some of them are good
but it's not usually like the kind of
thing i'm more into like indie stuff or
whatever but this this this film really
could have been something if they'd had
practical effects in it
and yeah practical effects and more like
more like the book ending yeah i think
it would have been a lot more memorable
and uh no rage zombies it should have
been more like something out of the
omega man and that way you'd have a
couple more characters in there that he
could interact with and that there could
be like a real story between him and
those things out there that would have
been a lot better
yeah because it does kind of go more
yeah it does kind of go more like
generic monster movie like zombie
apocalypse kind of direction and there's
been a [ __ ] zillion of those
so i kind of feel like maybe
i know you know it we can say this now
like back in 2007 it made like a [ __ ]
ton of money so obviously people liked
it but i think it would have been
remembered a lot more fondly
if they had gone like a slightly like
different direction i mean because the
because of the lore they basically had
permission to borrow from all those
other movies if they wanted to you could
have done a fish mash up of all the best
of all those movies and made a real
[ __ ]
super version of i am legend and it
would have it could have been like a
mega man but maybe a little bit more
like the book or a little bit like i am
i am le or uh last man on earth mixed
with kind of
will's take on it
and i think it should have he should
have been more
paramilitary
and uh
more of a darker figure more of a in a
way more of a villain to the to to the
to the mutants and the mutants could
have been maybe a little bit more like
vampires like they were in the book like
a little bit more like a vampire but
also kind of having aspects of a cult
kind of like an omega man
where they wouldn't use technology that
way you could balance it out or why they
couldn't just easily blow him out of the
[ __ ] because he's in a house he's in
a brown he's a stone house
[ __ ] one five 105 howitzer [ __ ]
just
blow that thing up like it was like it
wasn't even there you know one shot
collapsed that whole thing
so there had been a reason why these
vampires wouldn't just
do like what zachary says and omega man
let's go get us the cannon and blow them
out yeah just go blow them out there has
to be a reason why they don't do that
and i think the mega man handled that
well you could have had a really good
synthesis of them all and then and then
practical effects and practical stunts
this [ __ ] have been a classic has been
remembered today yeah
yeah like i said it's i people still
remember it but i think they remember it
mostly because like there's a pretty
good movie with a shitty ending yeah you
know what i mean
not
yeah oscar perez says dawn of the dead
from 2004 is far better i agree and the
thing about it is that and i'm not
usually like a big fan of hey if you're
gonna remake a horror movie why don't
you remake a crappy one instead of
remaking a good one
but
dawn of the dead from 2004 remake of the
george romero movie is actually pretty
[ __ ] good
uh one of the few remakes that came out
around that time of a good movie that
was actually it's not i don't think it's
better than the original but it's still
pretty it's a pretty [ __ ] good movie
in its own right and i saw that in the
theater and i was like wow i was like
blown away because i was thinking it was
just gonna be like some lame ass oh god
they're remaking more [ __ ] again but i
was like hey that was pretty [ __ ]
awesome but yeah that's i agree that
that that is a much better you should
have written and directed this movie we
should have been probably rob zombie
rob zombie loves you mega man and loves
[ __ ]
uh uh last man but see then it would
have been a genre film
and they wouldn't have made 600 million
dollars on it i don't know he did good
with [ __ ] house of a thousand corpses
that's true and then you have yeah
you have yeah i would have liked to see
that i'm just saying that from a from a
movie executive point of view they're
like they want to make 600 million
dollars on this have him retell
[ __ ] last man on earth and you know
have him retail i am legend and you
could put will smith in it as neville
and i think rob zombie i think
understood that story that all those
books and those stories better than the
public and he could have [ __ ] sold
that [ __ ] well somebody that's into
horror right because that's what it is
it's a horrible it's a horror novel
i mean you should get somebody that
knows about horror and that knows about
that book and somebody who loves that
story and all the movies that came from
that story and he and rob zombie could
have [ __ ] made a a real good one if
he'd had the money
and and the permission to do it yeah
sometimes when you say oh like rob
zombie should have made that i'm like no
he shouldn't have but that might
actually be a good idea i think that
would probably come out pretty good i
think he understood the tone
yeah i don't think he understood [ __ ]
and making it a horror movie you could
make it bleak you could make it just
like the book is and no one would [ __ ]
right and then you could have your
action sequences and you could have
the best of the stuff where they're
vampires basically mutant vampire people
they're in a cult
they're [ __ ] they're after him
they're kind of paramilitary also at
certain times and then you and [ __ ]
neville is a killing machine and he's a
scientist too and you can have all that
[ __ ] happening at once in an intense
horror action adventure and i think i
think rob zombie understood that
well
and you know not that not so much with a
lot of the tone the house of a thousand
corpses and [ __ ] some of his other
[ __ ]
some scenes like that okay but not as
goofy there's almost some goofy [ __ ] in
that
i don't think he understood um
oh halloween from what i heard didn't he
do a halloween and people were like what
the [ __ ] wasn't it i was like what the
[ __ ] i saw the rob zombie halloween
remake in the theater and i that was one
of i didn't walk out but that was one of
the first movies that i was like i don't
even think i want to like watch the rest
of this is [ __ ] terrible well like i
said and i've brought this up before
don't over explain your monster god
[ __ ] damn it i don't want to know
about michael myers as an abused little
child right it's not scary you're not
too much explanation yeah right zombie
just would have had a bunch of fighting
in it and a bunch of
car wrecks and trying to kill these
things the focus i think would have been
better i think he would have done a lot
better job
but like i said maybe he couldn't do it
on his own maybe you know a couple
rob zombie and a couple guys helping him
and a bunch of money i think would have
been good
danny rowling says uh chud and chud to
bud the jud review would be sick
i've been wanting to do that for a while
i think i put chud in the uh polls a few
times but it never wins
i don't have you ever seen shut or to
chad too by the shot those are a couple
that i always used to watch on uh on
cable he's a terrible [ __ ] director
no no he's not he's good it depends on
the material good he's good at certain
things and depends on the magic yeah and
uh
he mentioned
mentions these movies a lot in music and
he understands the all these stories and
in these movies real well i think you'd
have done a real good he loves this yeah
i mean as much as i hated his halloween
remake um
you know i i will give him one thing he
is super [ __ ] into horror he loves
horror [ __ ] and so you know but he has a
particular aesthetic yeah um you know so
whatever it is it's like a particular
thing he's good at but like some other
things i think he should probably like
keep far away from yeah danny rowling
also says also the 1991 tv movie called
the haunted
based on the smirl haunting would be
sick to see also it's free on youtube
like a review of that
i think i've seen that i remember that
being kind of good i might have watched
it when we when i was um writing about
the smurl haunting i'll have to write
that down because yeah i might actually
do that because i remember that being
like a pretty good some of the best
movies out there were not created by one
director okay even even the [ __ ] old
school star wars they're very
those first three movies
that was more like a group thing all
right lucas really
the best one was [ __ ] empire strikes
back and lucas had the least amount to
do with that one
[Laughter]
but it was like two or three guys
working together to kind of
get that [ __ ] to shape up and to edit it
right and um
and movies sometimes if it's like a
couple guys working on it and they have
the money and the time they can come up
with something better than just one dude
because
one man's limited
[ __ ]
yeah even pretty much everybody has to
have somebody around to tell them no
when they're doing projects like that
they'll go down to some [ __ ] path
that'll all get [ __ ] up
but um
[ __ ] that one rob zombie move a house
with a thousand corpses what was the
other one that he did there was like
three of them that were all kind of
they all had their [ __ ] cap spaulding
and [ __ ] what was the name of it um
what was the name of it jenny what the
house of thousand courses yeah that was
the other one there's like a sequel to
it devil's rejects devil's rejects those
two i thought they were great now there
was a third one
that he did it was okay it wasn't as
good as the other two but i thought
those two and that was kind of like his
own little [ __ ] series that he made
and i thought i did a great job with it
it was creepy [ __ ]
yeah
so i
i think he could handle i think i think
he'd be good to maybe not direct it but
advise on it at least
yeah i mean like i said at least get it
to help write the
it just seems like i wish that they
would kind of get a good balance of
because even though the last minute on
earth the vincent price version was a
horror movie it was super super low
budget it was aip like american
international pictures who were known
for just doing like cheap knockoff [ __ ]
um so i kind of wish that this was given
like a decent budget but also made like
a horror movie yeah instead of trying to
make it like a crowd-pleasing action
movie you know what i mean but these
these two movies in the book or were
like one of rob zombie's favorite [ __ ]
i'd have put him involved in it
somewhere because he knows it real well
um
yeah somebody oh uh jenny have you ever
done constantine review oh ask him
because this movie was directed by the
same guy that did constantine um we
haven't i've seen it i remember it being
really good keanu reeves is in there i
have it
do you have a comment i think i have it
you should look maybe we should like uh
maybe we should do that one of these
days i remember it being good although
it's been a long time since i've seen it
um let's see doo doo doo i saw oh straw
dog 78 said john carpenter could have
pulled it off in 2007 he had just done
cigarette burns oh yeah that's like a
good that's a good point cigarette burns
was easily my favorite uh episode of
masters of horror
with a young norman reedus matter of
fact and it was about like a cursed
movie and i love [ __ ] about cursed
movies i don't know why but like antrum
and all that kind of stuff i love that
kind of [ __ ] but yeah so
yeah maybe i mean that that might have
been cool john carpenter direct and
i am legend yeah that yeah i think that
could have worked actually maybe yeah
anybody who's more into doing i mean i
don't know maybe frank darabont yeah
maybe
could have done about sherry moon she's
hot but she's a bad actor she i don't
think she is an actress is she
she acts a little no she's just a
professional hot girl i don't know yeah
i don't think she's i mean she's an
actress in the sense that people point a
camera at yeah
i think yeah but yeah she just kind of
yeah i don't think she's an actress
she does kind of play the same character
in every single yeah which i'm assuming
is just her yeah i'm assuming that's
just what she's like that's what's what
i took it at yeah i don't think she's an
actress
he just puts her in the movie yeah which
that happens a lot that's a lot of those
hollywood movies are like that
especially low budget [ __ ] grind
house [ __ ] like he likes yeah put her in
it yeah yeah yeah that'll work yeah
whatever they're not actresses it's just
some hot chick they put in there that's
all it is well yeah because they figure
no one's going to care all that much if
she's now if they're ugly they have to
be a good actor yeah in that kind of
movie
yeah
but if you're hot it doesn't matter
we're not listening to what you say
anyways a lot of those hotties and those
[ __ ] grindhouse flicks were [ __ ]
hookers and prostitutes cookers and
strippers that's what they were in their
real life
especially in the 60s 70s
uh danny rowling says after this i'm
going to check out the franklin angela
dracula film never saw it look go into
it i always really liked it go into it
it's more like it's
i don't even know if i'd call it a
horror movie it's kind of a horror movie
but it's kind of like more like a dark
gothic romance sort of
so i guess in that way it's kind of more
like the francis ford copeland one in a
little bit
zach says i'd love to see y'all do
chinatown at some point yeah we probably
should
uh kanavasan said constantine is very
good yeah i remember liking it it's just
like been such a long time since i've
seen it
um
so all right
are we ready to wrap it up yeah i don't
know what we're gonna watch tonight so i
don't know what we're gonna talk about
tomorrow we could do godfather too
um we could do
uh we could do that swirl movie that
we're talking about we could look and
see if we have constantine if you have
it maybe we could do we could do that i
don't know but i don't have any idea
like what we're gonna come up with but
we'll come up with something uh so
hopefully you guys will drop by tomorrow
and see what we come up with so thanks
for dropping by today and have a good
rest of your evening and we will see you
guys again talking about another movie
tomorrow bye